então vou falar que a minha vida nós que
eu posso fazer e aí ela existe
campeonato vocês aqui na minha casa olha
como ela tá bonito porque irmã mãe
passou por aqui não está sozinho e
também ele também canta para fazer a
santa catarina
a situação está bastante e eu irei
cantar net eu assisti todos os dias
estou tentando diminuir um filme na
verdade eu sou um cara que gosta e eu
estava assistindo de novo mais comigo
porque doeu me apaixonei primeira vez
profissionais comigo que eu pensava que
o amor verdadeiro você cantar junto com
pessoas em pessoas sabemos que você ia
cantar acho que a minha letra não ficou
só de uma chance interessante filme
musical ou senão eu tô gravando achou
interessante filme musical seguinte as
pessoas começam a tocar um negócio nada
e do nada tirou o pé e sinfônica o cara
afinou meu deus ele afinou a porta a
porta
ela vai sair da minha palma da minha mão
dele eu não tenho um filme musical tudo
tem um som lindo maravilhoso eu jogava
contra o vilão mas afinal o profissional
só tocar no scalla banana panelas ao
santa maria e não chegar só que às vezes
o cara não sabe o que está acontecendo
começa a tocar o outro é tocado nada ele
ficar com basquete jogando seja de
basquete nota a gravadora qualidade
diante
ei
a ajudar
o que eu quero o meu deus
são os carros da escola pública ou de má
fé para que uma vez subir na mira do
chapéu achei que todo mundo começa a
dançar com ele tirar a roupa
eu odeio quando começa a sair para no
tróia gabriel entrar e cantá e não o
pioneiro quando a pessoa está
conversando aí do nada ela resolve em
que elas vão cantar eu entendo da
nintendo que foi bem
john minha vida tá tão base a om camapi
tudo vá resolver
é e agora vou pegar esse creme tá me
masturbar e eu logo junto ajudar a
equipe ter você acha que a gente deveria
fazer isso mesmo foi john eu acho que
sim porque esse crime é da jequiti então
vamos ser felizes homossexual
vamos lá e quando a pessoa acorda e ela
já acorda baterias o noia cordel
encantando os passarinhos alegres a
bailar
difícil é esse que me faz todo dia me dê
mais esse cara no bar de malhar mais e
hoje eu não sei por que eu vou me
alimentar porque eu posso até fritar um
ovo mas amanhã tem que fazer de novo
depois eu quero que você comece aqui
embaixo que você acha mais estranho o
que mais incomoda o que você acha mais
engraçado e filmes de musicais e como
aqui em baixo então você dá um like it
on
ou seja deu lhe no vídeo do scouting
caso isso ajuda muito no trabalho com um
pincel um cara muito legal assistir eu
sei a nunca eu acho muito ruim e vai na
lava que fingiu que amor não porque
minha filha nessa e eu vou me despedir
de vocês
amigos amigos eu queria também que você
inscrever no canal dos meus amigos que
me ajudaram a fazer este vídeo é o canal
do bryan
esse é o lado bruno e esse é o canal do
blog visita ao travar os caras não se
inscreveu no canadá os caras que você
vai ajudar muito e sei que ele também me
ajudar para fazer este vídeo é legal pra
vocês
então eu quem sou eu para julgar as
pessoas não são ninguém então você faz
me seguir no twitter que quisesse não
não posso fazer nada já está aqui pra
frente se todos nós amigos